[Musique]
le président du département cyrille
melchior s'est rendu aux salines de
saint-leu ce lundi 19 foot
il a effectué une visite du site en
présence de bruno domaine maire de la
commune et de béatrice sigismeau
président de la svm eden est vice
présidente du département
celui a bénéficié de travaux conséquents
pour que le sel de saint-leu reprenne
toute sa place dans la consommation des
réunionnais des touristes
c'est très important parce que j'irai la
production qu'on fait aujourd'hui est
acheté très rapidement ça veut dire que
des réunionnais les touristes aiment
bien la fleur de sel le sel de saint leu
et donc on doit en produire plus pour
que l'ensemble des réunionnais puissent
utiliser le seul dauphin le qui est très
apprécié pour atteindre les objectifs
attendus par le département la sbm eden
développera une stratégie de
commercialisation pour produire plus de
sel il faut d'abord réhabiliter les
bassins voyez que aujourd'hui il ya une
surface là qui représente à peu près 20
poisson qui a été remise en valeur mais
si on est hors met en valeur tous les
bassins on pourrait multiplier par cinq
la surface d'exploitation
deuxième condition il nous faut du
personnel qualifié du personnel formé et
ça on a commencé à le faire et à peu
près sept ou huit personnes qui ont été
formés pour pouvoir exploiter dans les
meilleures conditions et bien le sel de
saint leu et la troisième condition
c'est qu'il faut organiser
ben quand une fois qu'on a produit faut
vendre
on veut aussi au delà du musée du sel
aller vers une exploitation un peu plus
commerciale et c'est la spl éden qui va
faire tout ce travail le département à
accompagner la professionnalisation de
cette saunier dans le cadre d'une
formation dispensée par des
professionnels de la saliculture le
président a profité de l'occasion pour
leur remettre leur attestation de
formation
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]